the flash has gone rogue the wallets
gone hello when people think in the
flesh Pettitte in speech
purely scientific was she good looking
for the flash went nuts from Street to
freak
next time she punches me in the face
I'll be sure to get her number
hey youtubers is Charlie there's a new
female speedster important stuff first
is she hot did you get her phone number
I love that that's the first thing Cisco
goes to wait a minute there's an evil
lady speedster what does she look like
gimme some digits so who the hell is the
hottie well this is trajectory from the
comics if you don't remember her she was
a relatively minor character that
appeared during the 52 series not the
new 52 52 the weekly comic that came
right after Infinite Crisis but before
final crisis we were talking like 10
years ago so if you don't remember her
it's no big deal
in the comics she's not necessarily a
villain but the way she gets her powers
is a little bit different there are so
many different kinds of speedsters in
the comics but she's an artificial
speedster created by Lex Luthor using an
EXO gene treatment during something that
he called his everyman project as in
every man has a chance to get
superpowers and become a hero now as
we've learned most of Lex Luthor's plans
always have some sinister subplot so
what was going on is that in the wake of
Infinite Crisis Lex Luthor used a double
to blame all the terrible things that he
had done this double this is the one
that did all those awful things this is
the one that was trying to kill Superman
all those times I'm the true Lex Luthor
and I'm a good person see how much I'm
going to help humanity by giving
everyone the chance to become a
superhero the twist is is that Lex
Luthor has this master switch that
allows him to turn people's powers off
literally with the flick of a switch so
if he turns your powers off in the
middle of a fight you're completely
screwed and he does just that the other
big twist is that Eliza Harmon who's
trajectory's real name she cannot slow
down unless she takes a special drug now
it seems like they're changing a few
things about her character for the TV
show like she's gonna be a villain she
wasn't a villain in the comics but the
way she shows up in this trailer it
seems like she's working at mercury labs
and she finds a way to give herself
speed it just happens to use that for
mischief so maybe if she's gonna be a
villain she's gonna be more of a Captain
Cold villain where she does have a coat
like she does have a goal that isn't
totally bad but she's still robbing
people so the flash has to take her down
the look on her face here just looks
like mischief so it's not like she's
trying to kill the flash she's not like
zoom which is why I'm hoping they're
able to turn her to a certain point like
old and glider's a villain but she has a
lot of fun messing with Cisco and she's
not all bad captain cold is a villain he
is not all bad what is the deal with
them going on break though this episode
this trajectory episode isn't gonna air
till March 22nd so it's off the air for
a couple weeks
so is arrow but that's it just those two
shows there are couple shows that are
coming back like Gotham agents of shield
is coming back daredevil season 2 is
gonna premiere in the middle there
legends of tomorrow is still airing new
episodes every single week so there's
still a lot of stuff going on so what
I'm gonna do is a couple flash arrow
bonus videos while those shows are on
break there's still plenty of stuff we
can talk about I know everyone is still
going crazy about the mystery of zoom
like I said there are so many versions
of the reverse-flash in the comics you
could point to a lot of different plot
lines and say the TV show is borrowing a
little bit from these characters like
cobalt blue it's borrowing a little bit
from the Golden Age because that's where
Jay Garrick is from just remember when
it's all said and done the TV show isn't
doing a specific comic book storyline
he's just borrowing a lot of names in a
couple of twists from the comic books
it's combining a lot of different things
from different eras in the comics so a
new round of the flash giveaway starts
next week be sure to subscribe to get it
there's a new Batman V Superman Suicide
Squad stuff happening this weekend so
I'll probably do a new video for that
stuff there's some new Deadpool I'm
posting tonight so it's gonna be a
pretty cool weekend and if you didn't
see it yesterday I was I was teasing a
secret project that I've worked on with
syndicate and black nerd comedy that's
not gonna drop for a couple more weeks
I'm not allowed to say what it is until
it drops but it was pretty pretty cool
while you guys wait for me to post that
Deadpool video tonight you can click
here for that daredevil trailer I posted
yesterday you can just loop it like
three or four more times it's gonna be
so awesome Punisher is going to wreck
everyone it's gonna be so much fun and
if you haven't seen them yet you can
click here for all my Deadpool Easter
eggs thank you so much for watching
everybody let's high five I'll see you
guys tonight